all right welcome to my last begin a
breakdown of the year i'm your host Mike
comer and I'm in a lot of trouble on
double-secret probation here so so they
finally said enough goofing up I have to
actually teach today like something good
so we're going to be teaching a king and
pawn endgames okay so let's buckle down
and really try to learn something today
all right this was played from the
holiday chess tournament played last
week second place shocker was a Wilson
Gao so he's playing the white pieces and
let's see how he does in the final round
hey wait he starts out with the Kings
poem black counters with knight c6 so so
you know if they don't attack your e
pawn you can just go ahead and play on
d4 okay and so now d5 pass it up e six
so so black had a chance to play Bishop
f5 and rescue that Bishop from a from
impending doom but he played e6 and you
really just boxed it in it's a white
plays F for night out gets his night out
fish about Bishop to d3 so now White has
a complete control of this so so that
white Bishop is kind of powerful he's
aiming at h7 and if black ever gets
castled you know you'll have a threat
over there so so what do you think black
plays the counter Bishop to d3 how can
we attack the bishop on d3 night to be
four excellent yup so now the night
attacks the bishop he attacks the night
blacks like I wasn't bluffing Wilson I'm
taking your guy with Chuck and so Queen
takes
so black gets Castle white white does as
well and now black plays c5 so in Flex
position isn't looking all that bad here
he might actually have an advantage here
alright so takes it all right no he
doesn't take it he plays well let's see
what he does all right yeah he does take
it Bishop takes c5 check Bishop blocks
and so now he gets the Queen out so
Queen and Bishop are coming down on this
Bishop so he's gotta he's got to either
protect the bishop or he can just take
so now Queen takes check and the King
goes to the corner okay so black tries
to make the best situation out of his a
light squared Bishop that's been
entombed voluntarily so he's going to
try to get get it going s'alright brings
the night up Rick the c8 so now he's got
two guys coming down here so so a move
that white probably doesn't want to play
here is b3 or be four because you know
he would lose the night so got to think
about that so let's see what he actually
does do he plays Knight to d4 and not a
six so rook f3 so now you know he might
be thinking about playing rook to g3
maybe even Brooke to h3 so he's got
ideas of having him be part of the
kingside attack here so black retreats
with Queen to e7 brook to g3 so now the
rook is on the same line as the King
let's see if he can do anything with
that so rook to c4 and now white plays
the move that I do not recommend be
three ok so now black rooks is under
attack here but he's got a trick
possibly
what do you think black trick would be
in this position rook takes Knight Queen
takes and then what's the big follow up
Knight to f5 yeah and then the Queen
would retreat night check if I don't win
double pun so we take and now black can
play like Queen to c5 followed by Rick
to c8 even though he's not up any
material it's just he's got such a much
better position and and white cannot
really generate any kind of King side
attack h4 h5 will just easily be
countered with h6 so that's that's what
he really should have played instead he
just retreats the c7 so so now White's
the sides i'm going to get my king side
attack on and he plays the dreaded move
f6 so he takes Bishop takes Knight takes
Queen takes and now pawn takes up six
Queen takes f6 and and so now i can play
Queen takes d5 check but which would be
fine possibly if it gets the right
follow up because what like if it plays
Queen takes Chuck here King here and
then isn't really paying attention he's
like oh no my nights under attack maybe
I could just you know attack his Queen
here what does black play to win the
game no Queen takes work yeah yeah nice
one okay what if what if he's like oh
I'll just I'll just uh you know I'll
just protect the guy Queen up one check
rook takes or text me he could obviously
probably go
well if he goes back to d3 though this
gets kind of confusing too because you
can just come down and play rook takes
and then after Queen takes the same
thing checkmate so why it's got to be
really careful here so Wilson decides
I'm going to be really careful I've got
to play rook to f3 and attack the Queen
okay and so Queen goes back so rook
takes off a check Queen takes up a and
now Queen takes check and king so notice
in this position that the back row
checkmate is in play for both kings it's
very important to you know keep that in
mind because as you'll see some of the
tricks that come up in this game don't
work because of the backboard checkmate
isn't play as we'll see later all right
so Queen protects the night rook over
okay so he is not threatening back row
checkmate in this instance because rook
or whatever if i play a 4 rook rook
takes Queen takes Queen back okay all
right so all right so he's like all
right well I don't even want to even
pretend about the backward checkmate so
I'm gonna play King to g1 rook attacks
the Queen Queen retreat queen gives a
big check and guess what Oh back row
checkmate is in play now so now black is
really excited here he goes Knight to g4
we should really take a good hard look
at this position because black is
threatening a whole heck of a lot here
right he's namely night Chuck right ok
what's the only move we can play to a to
thwart you know him from from black from
winning here there's only one move every
other move losses
green to d8 you just lost the game
unfortunately
alright so what movie you want to play
play anyone you're going to lose how
about all i want to say my queen good
luck all right Queen to d2 check oh no
and then have you guys ever seen the
smothered mate God why it's not smarter
than me that's not so you got so lucky
you got so lucky all right so let's not
do this smothered mate let's play neck
let's play all right let's just win your
queen okay and just party's over okay
for his help all right so right so so
that doesn't work not because of the
smother mate but because Nate discovered
check loses the Queen you got lucky we
try h3 bad news you lose your queen just
outright only one move works here just
so everybody saw that at home after
Queen check rook Queen to d2 we're gonna
play check and then it's a discovered
check okay and the Queen has no good way
to block it and you'll win okay you
because you're in check all right so
here it is here's the knight to e to
help just check and check and you're not
looking very good so luckily Wilson is
like I'm not going to resign I'm going
to find the pesta move I don't care if I
have to sit here all day I'm going to
figure it out that you have any other
guesses how can we stop Ned of to check
without losing material
and it only works because notice Black
has the back row checkmate right night
to e4 rook takes me for fails miserably
to check mate okay so so nighty for is
the move so like we're Shizuka play work
takes night and be like I'm the best at
tactics but it doesn't work because of
the the backward check me so he plays
Queen to f8 now he's got now he's got
ideas of rook takes Knight again do we
have any ideas what we can do now once
again there's probably only one move
that to save everything because if we
don't play anything rook takes Knight is
coming and obviously if we move the
night anywhere it's a disaster forest
because of a night f to check so King to
g1 excellent Queen to so Queen see 50 we
would take the night queen of c5 is the
follow-up move to here now Queen the c5
as like darn done darn yeah so Queen now
fate wherever we don't want to resign so
we got to find the one and only move
here I know it's tough when you're when
you're in a in a position like this
maybe we just got to make a thread of
our own because his threat is obviously
rook takes Knight followed by the check
right what would we love to do if after
he takes the night obviously we don't
want to take his rook maybe we can make
a threat so we can take something else
of his so what's the only other thing we
can really threaten in this position of
blacks any bad guy any guesses because
this thread is rook takes Knight so
we're down a night so what do you think
we want to attack of blacks so he's
threatening to take or night so what
should we threaten to take of his maybe
his night right so when he takes we're
like we take in your rook buddy we're
going to take your night and we're going
to hope that it uh we hold on for dear
life here so he attacks the Queen throws
in a check King moves those in another
check brooke blocks and so now queen
green up so stops the back road
checkmate so now he plays Queen f1
threatening of course rook to f8 leading
the checkmate so black place King to g8
attacks the rook rook moves threatening
a big threat here rook to e1 so he's
like I'm not having any of that King the
g2 and now blacks like I'm going to end
all the back row checkmate scenarios and
just play h6
so this game should probably be a draw
the HL four pawns in a queen and rook
and it doesn't look like any players
anybody really has a chance for a
checkmate now that you know all the all
the back row checkmates are off the
table pens the rook he gets out of the
pen give them a check King back Queen
retreats rook attacks the Queen Queen
gives a check King up rook attacks the
Queen so so let me ask you what is the
Queen doing in this position what is she
protecting could you protect me a couple
things she's protecting the pawn the
pawn and the rook okay so all he has to
do is play Queen to d7 and he's
protecting everything right okay so
unfortunately plays Queen to f6 on
guarding the pond so Wilson's going for
it why not all right now so now rook up
clean to f3 so Queen takes King takes so
now we're in an endgame Wilson should
win this he's doing great because he's
got this rook making a big wall that the
King can never penetrate right you can't
you can't ever get get there so all he
has to do is run the sea pawn to victory
so King up rook over brooke threads to
take the rook so he plays rook through
there protecting the up on king over so
now black needs the seize the day and
get get at least a little closer if you
can so that really wasn't a good a good
little sequence for Wilson but he still
got a got him pinned off of this e file
Laurie stuck on the King side so now
yeah just rush
the pawn up there check I mean all these
checks you know don't really do much for
for Wilson but that's okay so rook check
King back so he can't get checked
anymore g5g for ok so now King back so
now why can continue advancing his
opponent if he once so so Wilson
shouldn't have had to be asked you know
to move the sea pawn but he was so he
plays it so King King up attacks the
rook so he needs to stay on the D file
so he just retreats all the way back to
d1 alright so King up King up three
check now if black wants to try and win
this game he really need a play rook to
f4 here try to get try to do something
here because if then if white would play
work did you want to protect it guess
what we can get over and get our King
you know black in the pawns which would
be ideal and if every Wilson smarty
plays well if you plays there then maybe
we trick them in was like okay I got
your past pawn now so work to f4 was the
best move to try here obviously I guess
Wilson would play here and fork the
pawns but you know at least I have my
own pass punt and you have something to
worry about you got to have an active
rook when he plays rook to c6 here it's
just not gonna just not going to do it
so now Wilson's like all right I'm going
to trade and you know if he moves the
rook it's not going to be a good
sequence for him so he's going to be
like are playing a kid it's very easy to
mess up these king and pawn in game so
why not
I'm going to do it so now like in the
opening you know I always stress you
know make your moves count don't be
moving around the same piece all the
time don't be blocking in your pieces
get cancelled time is very important
just like in the end games time is
precious if you make one little move
that you know kind of waste time that
could be the difference between winning
losing and drawing as we'll see here so
let's see how precise Wilson ends up
playing this to win remember we don't
want to waste time we want to have a
very active King just like in the
opening we went to active pieces okay so
let's check this out so King up
excellent okay because where is he going
he's going to go over here so we don't
want to waste time ago i got the
opposition or or or anything like that
it's like let's take the quickest route
to the pawns so he's like okay I've got
the opposition and this totally waste
time where does black need to be on it
yeah cuz because let's say in your ideal
world you know you get to protect these
pawns let's just say they start playing
silly okay okay then guess what's going
to happen I've now play here and then
here or whatever and then I got Queen
right so so you just wasted precious
time by playing that move okay because
you need to be over here so don't waste
time ok and this guy is actually rated
higher about 200 points higher than
Wilson so Wilson's like I'm not having
any of that we're not going to do an
opposition dance like 34 repetition I'm
going to go get up if you want a guard
through these Kings ipods i'm going to
get a queen site or queen so then ok so
now he's like ok you convinced me so now
Wilson's like okay I got to get rid of
that pawn so now he's got a passed pawn
so King up King up King takes
okay so now if we're goofing around and
just like well you know what there's no
way he can stop us I'm just going to
play here okay just for instance ya know
right don't play that right you want to
take the most direct path possible okay
how can black actually draw this game
now because it's like old man how can he
do it what trick does he have here yeah
push the pawn create your own passed
pawn cuz um if we take the pawn and then
he takes the pond in sufficient material
drop and then obviously if he plays pawn
takes guess what it's going to be a pawn
race and we'll both get there on the
same move draw assuming we don't play a
massive blunder like this it's like give
me a break okay do not put your king and
the Queen on your same line you know in
a king and queen end game okay alright
so but luckily Wilson's like I know what
I'm doing I'm going to play a king to g6
and obviously moves like this don't work
because we can just take it with the
king okay and so the game plays out and
much to his chagrin it's all over okay
dad and that's that okay beta twelve
Wilson is 1604 chagrin is about 1864
alright so now we'll see a game where
against lower rated opponents where we
have you know a maid in 13 or something
but we screw it up because we're not
precise with our moves alright so
so black is the hero he's actually a fan
of beginner breakdown which I always
like to meet fans and everything and
it's cool so so let's see how david
thomas does all right so he's playing
out 1300 and david is rated less than
1000 but you know he's going to play to
the bitter end and see what happens so
they start out with the sicilian and a 5
i'm not really a fan of because you know
you're creating a hole for for the night
but okay Knight to f5 and this position
I will probably just take it you know
but alright so Knight to c6 night to e3
you talked about you know time is really
important in the in the opening just as
well as the end game and it's like
you're moving around this night way too
much and you can't resist moving it one
more time so so look at this well castle
castle Bishop out and now he's like okay
I move it one more time so look at this
we both got castled and there were one
two three and we have four out and we're
and we got the moves second so so black
is winning out of this opening because
white is really wasting a lot of time
with this night so he's like I'm if you
want to make another night move buddy go
for it so he's like all right one more
so check and Bishop takes so so black
has really improved his position while
White's been wasting time all right so
Bishop out b6 Queen to d2 Rick d8 work
you want that's another reason why I e5
isn't the best because you know this
pawn is a backwards pawn now it's a
weakness this d 5 square you can come in
at any time but alright so now Knight to
e5 late to d5 alright so Knight takes
the bishop with Chuck Queen takes Bishop
takes
takes so are we doing some trades and
you know everything looks okay so Queen
Queen moop so he's attacking the a pond
he's attacking the e pawn alright so now
he plays rook to d1 so he's got two guys
coming down there so he takes the e pawn
and I guess the reason why he doesn't
take now which looks sensible because
after rook takes rook takes so remember
we always want to look for undefended
pieces and pawns that's how tactics
alright so what tactic do we have in
this position yep double attack alright
so it's like I'm going to attack your
queen first and it's like okay I'm just
play Queen to b4 anyway but now he's got
see three attacks the Queen and protects
so it plays Queen to a for attacking the
pawn I guess he doesn't play b3 here
because he would just play Queen to c6
and protect us pull okay so he's like
okay I'm going to take your guy I'm
going to take your guy rook takes Bishop
takes rook the D to double protect the
pawn pushes the pawn alright so now he's
got two men coming down on the bishop
the queen is attacking the bishop
through an x-ray so it moves a bishop
rook attacks the bishop Queen protects
the bishop Queen moves alright so now he
continues with a four so now he offers a
queen trade so blacks like well I got
one two three four five six pawns you
only have five consolidating is good for
me
alright so so if he knows consolidating
is good for him he really should play
rook the d8 here can't believe he
doesn't play with the d8 here all right
so he's like I'm not going to get back
row checkmated keep in mind you will not
have to worry about getting back row
checkmated right if there's no works on
the board all right so anyhow he plays
the move h6 and now look look how more
active White's rook is than blacks where
it's a Rick to c8 king up to King up
eight this is good they're both getting
their kings involved in game you need
your Kings involved in the end game it's
paramount and yeah he's coming coming
toward it and yeah if you move the Kings
diagonally as you notice it they go a
lot quicker right then get get there a
lot faster all right so it's like the
express lane the diagonals all right so
rook up b5 looks pretty natural right
here right you know attacking my pawn
protect it with a pawn instead by
playing Chuck here right I mean he gets
the King to where he once the bb5 would
have also kept the King out of c4 but
alright alright so f5f three now in this
position I would go for the really big
big move g5 here okay instead he's kind
of like in a hurry too much in a hurry
here and plays F board so pawn takes
pawn takes Bishop there so now g5 so
King the d3 what did he just do with
King to d3 put his [ __ ] up in a pin
right so be 5c for all right so c4
is kind of a you know kind of attacking
the punching at the base okay train de
trying to get it okay so if you would
play check the nest guys undefended ok
trying to undermine it that's what I'm
trying to say ok trying to undermine his
punching alright so so c4 so now he's
just going to go for it Bishop attacks
the bishop pawn takes check King back
rook takes pawn so now it's not looking
good for a black here not looking good
at all he was doing really good now not
so good he's only got three pawns
compared to four and two of white pawns
are passed so when he takes and trades
everything this is a disaster right an
absolute disaster but you never give up
a king of putting it because as we saw
we have tricks ok so now King up and so
White's like I'm going to go I'm going
to gobble this pawn this pawn this pawn
and then my H pawn is going to become a
queen his dad's all sin there smilin
like you're the best you give the best
we're going to have a ice cream after
the game it's going to be a great car
ride home but let's check it out but in
this position white plays a devastating
blunder here after he King takes pawn
he's like no worries I'm going to go get
your H pond and life is good so it
probably just went from mate in 13 for
white to about mate and 18 for black so
what's blacks huge move here g4 right so
I'm going to get my own past pond and
there's nothing you can do about it now
the dad doesn't smiling so much yeah
it'll leave the tournament hall and if I
leave the room and screw
in this car ok so here it is so fond
takes so let's go back well well let's
watch this game and then we'll see what
what white should have done to win the
game well actually let's look at it
right now so King takes so what move
does white have to make to just seal the
deal ok because we obviously is that
King to f6 is devastation because of the
move g 4 h3 excellent so now maybe he
could try this but I don't think it's
good it's too slow let's take this pawn
and black skin can't stop them both yeah
it's all right it's all okay residing
okay all right so so we have to cut off
his counter play here okay so so he
thought he was doing everything great
king of six but it just loses I mean he
could try and him he does try but to no
avail Chuck loses a pawn another check
check bring the king over pins the pawn
brings his King up obviously if G right
well he's got made no matter what how
does black made them here checkmate yep
so that's it so that's that's the game
and by the way if you ever have let's
just say it's not mate here let's say
let's say he plays up here like this a
great way to play that is just put the
Queen right on the same cleaning file as
a pawn and then there's nothing he can
ever do to get it and then you can just
end and the game so nicely okay but yeah
checkmate and David came back with a big
win there he didn't give up right even
though he was down upon in a king and
pawn in game you know mistakes happen
right ok so we've learned enough about
King upon end games of how about we end
the year with a funny game okay all
right this is why we really tuned in
okay we got a game from one of the
floorboards okay we got a new new little
prodigy coming up erin lynn who scored
the biggest upset of the day
uh against the Robert Beekman okay so
Aaron's got the black pieces night of
396 and you know they're playing okay
whites whites opening is kind of weird
because as you'll see you know he got
castle which is good h3 so he retreats
his bishop but as you see he's got he's
got all the doors open as they say right
he's got this way to get out his bishop
that way to get out of this way to get
off this room this way to get our bishop
it's good to just just pick one and go
with it so queen of d7 attacking the
pond so King up so now queenside castle
so Aaron like a lot of kids when you're
playing kids you should you should
expect them to be very very aggressive
so so though the castle lake on the
opposite side of you and just just try
to beat you so so I like it so it get
lets the pawns go so Roberts like I'm
going to retreat my night so just keep
pushing the palms out so Queen f3 so
he's attacking our night so we got to
protect it so bishop moves off the back
row but not really targeting too much so
now he's got all look at how many people
he's got in the fight now he's got two
rooks a night I'll bishop a queen you
know he's threatening to get his Knight
up here so Aaron's doing this good he's
a he's just waiting to strike here and
now with bishops III I mean he's just
tempting them to strike with g4
obviously if we took here it would be a
major blundered discovered Chuck and we
win your corn alright so Robert sees it
and I Moses queen okay so he takes the
pawn bishop takes and now I get a big
check in
King the g2 and now he's trying to break
open the G file with the rook and the
night and the King on it so wipe the
size i got to try to get my own
counterplay going with B for break open
the B file so he obliges so rook attacks
the Bishop Bishop back alright so now
he's going to redirect his Queen to try
to get a an attack going yes pawn takes
okay so yeah obviously we don't want to
take here because what would a black
play to devastate white knight to e
three check yep the fork alright so so
he decides I'm gonna I'm just gonna make
a run for it okay good luck this is this
is really really dangerous so night to
h2 was played with check and then so
King e 2 instead he wants to remove the
defender well I take the rook but how
should actually taking the rook is bad
because after Knight takes rook what's
not bad I mean black is still crushing
but how should obviously a white tank
back here with the bishop right save the
bishop so yes so in your in your opinion
yet just play a [ __ ] Bishop takes
Knight takes and then we're just up a
solid piece okay but Aaron's like Brooks
are better than nights I'm going to take
it and unfortunately he takes back with
the king so pawn takes attacks the
knight Knight to f3 rook takes
King moves broke 2 G 2 beautiful move
and now queen or even though even though
work the g one might be better work the
g2 is just beautiful anywhere but oh
well so alright Queen to be three now
then now the computer announces mate in
five here who do you think's going to
win black or white you never know you
never know in these games right can
never know all right let's take a poll
we're not going to actually say the
number we'll just give the give the
percentages all right remember it is
black the move who votes that black is
going to win here please raise your
hands if you think black is going to win
all right and so so I assume the other
people say white is going to win no so
your vote for black oh ok so we have
what's your vote events all right so we
have to vote well we have a majority and
undefeated both parka black and one oh
man this is too close to call ok so
sorry so here we go all right so so
plaque so we have a matin five here for
four black what do you think's guys
started maybe maybe Grandmaster been
Feingold's coming in maybe he all right
promote the paw double check queen ok I
love it all right so that we only have
one legal move here King takes here ok
all right so we got four moves to check
made them here
alright work to F 2 i'm on board i'm a
board alright so the bishop is
protecting so obviously if we go here is
this
but take bishop is some bishops in check
let's take this night maybe because look
at this Queen mates yeah I'm good I'm
good I could see ya I gets these simple
mates all right so--okay so he plays
king to e1 ok so do we have any ideas
how to checkmate yeah we don't wanna go
to a we're like that then we really
would that we really would fall for his
checkmate here I don't really see a
checkmate for white though ok so look at
h1 check night rook now we got to be
really careful here how do we take his
night with the rook on the G rook or the
F rock or does it even matter she is
better because it's checkmate and that's
the name of the game thank you for
another successful year of a beginner
breakdown and I gave you guys the
meaning of life I mean what else do you
want the original box the really good
box and up alright see ya in 2016 thank
you
Oh